Poland for poles poles for Poland the
slogan at a nationalist demonstration on
brought Slavs market square much a man
dealt and imelda machine go have been
hearing sentiments like this more often
since the start of the refugee crisis
man dealt has been working for a
tolerant culturally diverse frats law
for years now he works for an NGO and
keep statistics on attacks on foreigners
and they're on the rise multicultural
Ross suave at the moment that's just a
slogan a fairy tale to attract tourists
and companies to the city imelda machine
go has been studying physics in francois
for three years now she was born in
poland and she's also working for change
she knows what it's like to look
different here when the nationalists are
on the march
she keeps out of sight again does his
lips it as an sake
denis monopoly citizens name my
boyfriend and i've had to call the
police to escort me home
i just couldn't get past the
demonstrators they kept threatening me
and saying i had no right to be here
Nagappa so we're fraught Slav and the
companies that have settled here depend
on young creative talents from all over
the world the IT sector is especially
cosmopolitan in both Outlook and human
resources people from nearly 20
countries among them India Argentina and
Italy work at Google rut Slav
Agnieszka or Buffs qey a manager at the
frost law office prefers to stress the
city's perks as a business location what
else office shipments rush off is a
great place
Google isn't the only company with
offices here we benefit from the good
business climate entrepreneurs and
international companies get a lot of
support here and it's also a great place
to live the city is also home to some
150,000 students and to one of Poland's
best technology universities its
graduates are in high demand another
selling point for international
companies not long ago the Startup
Weekend true creative business minds
from all over the world 80 participants
presented their ideas the best ones came
away with funding to help launch their
companies Poland is changing especially
now that the nationalist conservative
Law and Justice Party is in power
Harry Sondhi comes from India and has a
start-up in fretsaw he's a successful
entrepreneur but he also prefers to
avoid the topic of politics I moved in
voter in 2012 and after six months like
when I was banging my head on the wall
because I couldn't find someone who is
like-minded and honestly it was the
starter we canvassed or we'd have
changed everything and I never looked
back for that account
Fabien Lee kum has been living and
working in China for years he'd like to
start a company there and he's looking
for workers here and also Poland is
known for being very very good
developers and very cheap so I gave me a
clue
especially for developers because in
China they're quite expensive but he
would never consider living in Poland
after three weeks of traveling around
the country he feels disheartened by the
mood here
this resistance to Muslim because you
see it in the train stop Islam stop
Muslim you see the view on the drums on
the bus stops stop Islam and sometimes
people can insult you for no reason
the graffiti on every corner reflects
the divisions in polish society some
like much a muddled are prepared to
welcome refugees but others aren't
I believe you can change anything this
year bro swap is a European Capital of
Culture it's a great opportunity to show
the city can be multicultural and
open-minded
ma che mandals is optimistic
he believes brats love can be open and
welcoming to everyone